maybe there's something about being a
superhero or super villain that makes
somebody a little more prone to violence
because Anthony Starr one of the leads
of a hit Amazon Prime show the boys was
arrested for assault in March of 2022 in
Spain star was in Costa Blanca at a pub
apparently Anthony had beef with the
chef named batul araujo and araujo
claimed Anthony who was quite inebriated
punched him in the face twice which
would have been a bad look already but
star upped the ante when he also smashed
a glass on araho's face araujo ended up
needing four stitches from the glass
when I originally heard about the arrest
I was like well there goes season four
of the boys but star managed to get off
relatively scot-free he spent a couple
nights in a local Spanish jail and then
got a 12-month suspended sentence he
also had to pay almost 5 500 bucks to
arajo though I imagine that amount gets
covered by like an afternoon of work on
a mega hit Amazon show